can I ask you about Trump specifically I
I actually respect how you kind of
framed the whole situation it doesn't
sound like
[Music]
you are the one of those blindly
ignorant people they're like I just hate
him and I don't like what you actually
gave him credit you said he's a
worldclass demagogue right so there's
sort of like a humble brag right there
but you know who he is and you respect
your enemy you know Pat's newest book
choose your enemies wisely you've chosen
Trump as your enemy whether uh that's
vocal or not um you kind of laid out the
the top three uh characteres of uh the
type of person to r a campaign I want to
talk about the Trump voter you know as
as uh Bill Maher famously said it's okay
for you to hate Trump but you can't hate
the people that vote for him so in my
opinion there's three types of Voters
that vote for Trump there's the I love
my poorly educated people you know like
the Trump base you know millions of
people that just whether it's tribalism
whether it's instinctual they're just
like that's my guy you know he said he's
the middle finger to America and
rightfully so for some people right
they've been screwed over manufacturing
you talked about personal finance issues
um paycheck to paycheck all that so
that's number one on the other side of
the spectrum you have maybe the donor
class the millionaires the small
business owners in some capacity that
are look I'm I'm just voting for tax
reasons you know it's the economy stupid
so let's put those two on the on the
separate wings but then you have the
majority of people let's say it's 60% of
the people of the 80 million votes or
whatever 76 million votes who are like
just like no I don't like what's going
on the left I'm more I'm a conservative
I'm a Christian I'm you know I want to
raise my children in the right way at
the end of the day Trump can say what
other have he wants to say those people
are going with him and these are
hardworking Americans these are people
who love America they love freedom they
love democracy so at what point are
those people like they have a voice too
it's not like they are being Gunn to
their head you have to vote for Trump
you know you you've been with the
Lincoln project very adamantly against
Trump what would you say to those people
who essentially you're trying to
convince those types of people not to
vote for Trump but they're going to vote
for him anyway how do you handle that I
don't I mean these people at some level
are my parents okay right right so this
is this is family this is I mean my I
was on the Trump bomber Target list I
didn't get a bomb but apparently when
the FBI came to the house I was at the
top of the next back
um my parents still voted for
him right right so I I don't I don't
hate I don't hate the Trump voters um
you know I love some of them very much
um here here's what I would say
to the many millions of people that are
watching this that that vote for
Trump I get it
I I
get the disdain the
corruption within the
system there's a painting in the capital
of the United States it's a painting of
George
Washington and this is the moment that
America
functionally comes to
life in the painting George Washington
is in uniform
there's a chair there and the and the
chair is is bigger than the others in
the room it's the
throne that he will not sit on and
Washington lays his cloak over it he
will not be Caesar and he bows to the
Congress he walks away from Power
twice our American civilization
our our way of
life is
constructed around the assignment of
power through the result of an
election where
lawfully people raise their hand take an
oath and they're giving limited power
for a limited period of
time and never have the power to
interfere with some basic rights the
first time Donald Trump said in
2015 the election results are only
legitimate if I
win should have been a moment of a
national timeout I don't care if you're
on the far
left you're on the far
right in this
country that's not how it
works and so over these years
we've seen the escalation of that to a
moment where I think it's in real danger
if I was running that fox debate my
first question would have been let's
talk about how we're going to execute
General
Millie right we're going to shoot them
we're going to hang them poison them gas
them what do you think how how are we
going to shut down Comcast and MSNBC and
NBC I think and I don't understand why
not because I have a very basic premise
I take everything that everyone says
literally and
seriously
period if you say you're
running to seek
retribution to kill the joint CH Chiefs
of
Staff okay we we got a
problem right what what we share in Comm
in this country is a is a lineage of
defiance of
Entrepreneurship of pioneer
Spirit of of a defense of an
idea served in the 101st
Airborne
um these are sacred things in this
country and there's no man who is who is
above them and so in a choice between
two flawed parties two flawed people I I
get
it but at this moment as we come into
the third decade of the of the 21st
century country's got real problems it's
got real
opportunities I personally think if if
you had a dollar to invest anywhere in
the world you're a if this is the
place you don't put the dollar um this
is the most competitive Society on Earth
Earth but man is our politics broken
broken and when you got a guy like
Menendez right um who comes out you're
like okay let's hear it right let's hear
it right and he's like no you don't
understand right I had to sew the money
into the jackets because of the old
country
got years I gotta be ready a country he
wasn't born in he's never he's never
been into right so it's like it's
constant and I get it Joe said this like
on on Morning Joe the other other week
and this is totally true mhm he said
every single Democrat who comes on the
air 100% of them
say on the air something completely
different from what they say off the air
regarding Biden and here's the deal it
was exactly the same way with the
Republicans about Trump in 2015 and 2016
and either way both
sides the American people get this they
they completely intuitively understand
it's all whether it's Mendez in
the all in the Old
Country Diane Feinstein um passed away
right before before we came on air um I
was actually talking to someone about
this yesterday right like the the
notion this person who's a who's a
legitimately
important figure right in American
political history for for women uh the
how she came to how to power completely
stripped of her dignity in the last five
years of her service that that this is
what she'll be remembered for is is is
sitting up there uh with no faculties no
no no personal agency so so we have a we
have a massive problem
you have a belligerence in the media
that you see assert itself every time
someone says well you know 80% of the
country doesn't want Trump or Biden um
so there's a lot of Brokenness I
understand it but the issue with Trump
that's front in Center it has to
be are the intimations towards violence
towards chaos and the assassination
baiting of a guy who spent his entire
career wearing the cloth so if you like
this clip and you want to watch another
one click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here